il
oh
restés amis générosité et de courage ce
dynamique et courageuse duo je suis que
ce n'est pas cela
j'ai trois enfants je suis marié je suis
co gérant de la société des pâtissières
bonjour donc mamie rabenja mine à 43 ans
quatre enfants marié aussi co gérante et
associé de la société les pâtissières
chocolat froid allez que si toi quand
j'arrive au timing c'est quand on n'est
pas en vacances c'est plutôt je dois
être à telle heure à l'école parce que
le matin en fait moi c'est christine qui
ouvre et moi je m'occupe de mes filles
donc la dernière est celle qui n'est pas
encore réveillé pour les amener à
l'école publique commence à 8h l'autre à
8h30 donc le timing c'est plutôt ça a
tout à fait pouvoir amener ses enfants à
l'école et après je commence ma journée
de travail et du coup le soir celle
inverse cre estime qu'il doit partir
pour récupérer sa fille et moi j'assure
parce que c'est mon mari qui va chercher
les miennes le fait de tout son coeur
avec tous ces moyens aussi bien
intellectuel que physique la créativité
l'imagination tout en assumant son rôle
de mère de famille de quatre enfants est
un petit gars là vont partir lui qu'ils
travaillent pour quelqu'un qu'ils
travaillent pour elle maintenant c'est
pourquoi battait
les femmes souvent elles font pas ce
genre de métier quoi et c'est bien
qu'elle travaille pour personne puisque
conçu on peut pas on peut pas laisser la
casquette des pousses de femmes de mam
en dehors ça veut dire qu'il faut que je
gardais dans la tête un petit coin où on
se dit ce soir qu'est ce que je fais à
manger
attention il ya des lessives à faire
tourner
une sortie scolaire dans deux jours il
faut prévoir le goûter au cou on a beau
être chef d'entreprise et être en
pleinement ici on lâche pas le reste
zack est partie cas où tu as les filles
bonne journée
et capitule ce qu'on a dit 10h30
10h30 il ya le mariage donc il ya deux
pie-ix 50 personnes à sortir le cake
créole a décoré dont c'est parti
on s'est retrouvés par hasard on a eu
les mêmes envies un moment donné de
notre vie une belle rencontre départ
c'était juste un rêve en fait on était
plusieurs à rêver à haute voix en se
disant qu'il fallait qu'on en fasse cela
notre métier qu'il fallait qu'on fasse
quelque chose de bien
et puis on fera nos murs qu'ont passé
les états ont essayé de concrétiser ce
rêve c'est christine et moi qui sommes
restés jusqu'à la fin ça a commencé par
des belles paroles on va faire ceci on
va faire cela puis ça finit aujourd'hui
par une entreprise qui existe depuis
octobre 2012 il faut savoir qu'on
faisait partie de notre groupe
les personnes les plus âgées donc avec
un peu plus de maturité et surtout on
savait on voulait partir
voilà nous à partir du moment où on
s'est inscrit à la farce était on savait
qu'on avait un projet professionnel
derrière et une volonté justement de
reconversion donc voilà à la base moi
j'ai une formation de comptabilité donc
c'est un virage à 360 degrés donc voila
mais sinon voilà on c'est plaisant dans
la pâtisserie y en a même qui peu à
l'étroit c'est vrai parce que bon mais
chacun sait ce qu'il a à faire
on était toutes les trois polyvalent et
je trouve que la quarantaine
la cinquantaine sont des bons usages
pour rebondir parce qu'en fait on a on
est peut-être débutants reconversion
dans un métier mais on a un passif on a
un historique
on a des compétences personnelles
familiales professionnelles qu'on peut
mettre en avant et haut niveau c'est ce
qu'on a fait contre que veut nous ça a
marché clairement parce qu'on est le on
n'aurait pas pu tout seul ni moi ni
christine créer une entreprise ça a
marché parce qu'on est deux parce qu'on
est les deux bonnes associé qu'il
fallait pour les pâtissières
oh
ans
ban
on
marché
je pense qu'il ya la place pour tout le
monde et puis on est aussi on a fait
aussi un concept qui fait que quand les
clients viennent nous voir travailler
on leur donne des conseils et on leur
donne leur vend le gâteau qu'ils sont
directement confrontés est prête
2 nous directement on leur dit
clairement qu'on veut un retour ils ont
la possibilité d'influer sur le gâteau
qui va être fait et de dire on retour
oui c'était comme je voulais c'était bon
ou il faudrait faire ceci pour la
prochaine fois voilà oui il ya un
rapport particulier avec nous qui
fabriquons il apparemment il ya un effet
boule de neige positif il ya un effet
association entre christine et moi on
est très différente on est très
complémentaires
on n'était pas à mener en dehors de la
société les pâtissières à se rencontrer
à se croiser à se fréquenter
et peut être que c'est ça qui plaît je
sais pas on doit dégager peut-être
quelque chose dont on ne se rend pas
compte mais on vous avait dit quand on a
gagné le prix julie masse que notre
association elle c'est ça qui a fait
qu'on a gagné le prix julie masse notre
association avec d'étonnantes détonante
y a que des femmes
voilà c'est penser j'ai pas le droit de
rentrer c'est réservé aux femmes geste
in lorsque tu arrives et n'avaient pas
d'emploi et elle avait en tête de faire
tendre à une activité pour moi c'est
facile parce que vous êtes chez toujours
dans la même entreprise on va dire mais
elle elle doit s'adapter à nouveau se
recréer un relationnel en dehors de la
vie professionnelle
et puis de trouver l'activité c'est
difficile de rester sans rien faire
accouché il ya une congé maternité une
période d'inactivité puis ensuite cette
formation de patissia donc changement de
rythme de longues journées des départs à
4h ou 5h du matin des retours tardifs
des stages des enfants une grosse des
organisations et des rythmes
perpétuellement à retrouver et ça c'est
un peu c'est un peu compliqué en plus du
changement d'environnement du mes
changements de relation des amis des
parents etc
oui c'est un peu compliqué oui y'a pas
de secret on ferait que soi même fait
soi-même gérante confiance
on n'a jamais douté de notre projet on
n'a jamais douté de notre projet on n'a
jamais douté l'une de l'autre
on a appris il ya eu des hauts et des
bas on a appris à faire face à ce revers
est ensemble
et oui on ne doute pas c'est vrai qu'on
ne doute pas
un nouveau légume et d'intéressant c'est
qu'elle cherche toujours
elle cherche les produits pays c'est à
dire c'est vraiment parce que souvent
par le produit saison produits saison on
se rend compte que la majorité des gens
d'être avec des produits importés donc
qu'ils n'ont pas de rapport et les
produits saison alors qu'elles
recherchent vraiment les produits de
saison
par exemple à on attend le tamarin parce
que le tamarin et va pas chercher il va
pas tarder à sortir elle travaille de
tamarin sur le macaron je crois c'est ça
donc dès que le bac dès que le tamarin
va sortir un bal bon travail et donc on
est vraiment on suit vraiment le rythme
des saisons et ça je peux vous assurer
que c'est de plus en plus rares alors le
constat c'est qu'il n'y avait pas
beaucoup de produits péi et produits
locaux dans les pâtisseries il n'était
pas mis en valeur
en tout cas pas autant qu'on le
souhaitait vous pouvez trouver des
mousses de patates douces ou de
goyaviers
mais comme si les pâtes ici n'allait pas
jusqu'au bout et parce qu'ils ont reçus
sans doute une plus longue formation que
nous et qu'ils ont été plus dans le
moule on va dire de la pâtisserie
française
eh bien il reste plus attaché au
classique donc au praliné aux marrons à
la cerise aixois la framboise alors non
les zèbres ses classiques dont on se dit
que pour se démarquer puisqu'on était
pâtissière débutante chef d'entreprise
débutante
il fallait pas entrer dans le classique
où on allait trouver plus fort que nous
il fallait se démarquer et travailler
autre chose voilà être original donc on
a décidé de travailler au jour
d'aujourd'hui cercle à patates douces
mais pas sous forme de mousse sous forme
vraiment du gâteau patate traditionnel
de travail et le coco citron vert le
combat va parce qu'on travaille aussi le
fruit de la passion local j le litchi
locale voilà et puis on veut encore
parce que c'est pas fini on veut
travailler le chouchou le jambon le
tamarin voilà on a encore de quoi faire
et de pâtissière oui on a envie que ça
dure on a envie que j'ai plein d'autres
filles de la part de partout d'ailleurs
en fait vous trompiez web qui entre la
qu'il travaille et acheter les cartons
si ma fille mais je lui souhaite le
meilleur
fait normal c'est de devenir la première
pâtisserie des lilas c'est clair nous
c'est vraiment s'épanouir dans ce métier
de réussir à l'expansion d'associer le
goût est là
le tarif est là
les choses
on t'a fait merci
et